you were
a young man you were on fire you wanted
to be famous was your goal to be famous
honestly
no honestly my goal was to be rich and
famous
good evening i'm chevy chase and you're
not chevy he was
really the breakout star and he was
spectacular and
really huge he really took the focus
that first year he was amazing
oh the post office announced today that
it is going to issue a staff
commemorating
prostitution in the united states it's a
10-cent stamp but if you want to lick it
it's a quarter
you left saturday night live after a
year and you've even said you regret
having left so early it would have been
fun to be there for a couple of years oh
sure
you know and you laugh because you love
the woman and all of you yeah yeah and i
bet you it was hard for you to turn on
the tv
and watch all those guys doing their
thing i never did you never did you
never looked back i was busy
looks like we have a special urgent
weekend update bulletin coming in on our
dancing end
you hated doing weekend update you
wanted to be characters you didn't it
wasn't my fit
why i wasn't fit for that yet you were
great at it well i i was dry i wasn't
funny
this urgent bulletin just in no bulletin
today i just felt like dancing
backwards said that he hated being the
anchorman but when he did the jane
curtain bit where he said genuine
ignorance
that's like an all-time [ __ ] great
bit but again it's interesting because
dan
even when you watch that clip you
realize oh he was he was playing a
character like that was the only way
that it was interesting to ackroyd dan
there's an old saying behind every
successful man there's a woman
a loving giving caring woman but you
wouldn't know about that dan because
there's no old saying about what's
behind a miserable failure
jane you ignorant [ __ ] you walked into
saturday live second season
the first week i came they just gave me
a tryout and
they gave me three great scenes to do
and i i nailed them all
and so lauren said well i guess you'll
be moving to new york best supporting
actress and actors
who cares really honestly
i thought you and bill murray were
always at each other's throats true not
always
but a lot of times right you replaced
him and you guys got into a fist fight i
mean your brother had to break it up it
was it's
it's a funny story it was a hollywood
fist fight i went to host
and i went in i was probably a little
full of myself after a year of fame or
whatever
i think that billy probably wanted to
knock me down a couple of rungs
it was like an edible thing because
chevy left
the original people felt like he'd left
them in the lurch like
how could you do that we were all
running together so there was that and i
sort of was the avenging angel as the
new guy
words were said just before the show oh
that's possible
and i immediately got into a fight
stance you know we're both good-sized
fellas yeah
my brother is smaller than robin and he
broke up the fight
so that's how serious it was it wasn't a
real don't touch my face
weekend update with kevin nealon what do
you think it is in you that makes you
want to perform
there's probably something in me that
needs the attention and i like making
people laugh
i think it's you know if there's a rush
from that it's adrenaline
now let's take a look at today's most
active stocks apple is up three quarters
and
is down a half the flip is up six and an
eighth
neck is up a quarter and zero glimplin
is down a half
who did you take over the news from
kevin from dennis miller and he was
so good at it when you have to follow a
guy like that it sucks right
like you're like oh [ __ ] i don't want to
follow this guy well yes and no
you know it sucks because he was really
good and it's hard to follow that i want
to follow someone who sucks yeah
somebody crappy
you know yeah norma macdonald had that
job yeah
yeah that's right thanks i'm nora
mcdonald and this is the fake news
they said you got to say something at
the start you know signature line
right and i said what if i just said
it's the fake news because it's not
really
fake news it's some real news it's real
news
with a twist yes it's not fake with a
point of view afterwards
i would read in little articles you know
jon stewart's great that the fake news
you know right and it became like isn't
that strange
well it is finally official murder
is legal in the state of california
you are the uh shining light on saturday
night live the best part of saturday
live is when you do the news
right now i hear that he's been fired
from the show
why did they fire you how did they fire
you how do they tell you they're firing
you tell me everything
the guys go hey man you gotta call this
dude don ohmeyer is the president of uh
the network so when you called donald
meyer what did he say he said
he didn't want me to do uh update why
because uh
he doesn't think i was funny he said
that to your face he said
update is like dragging down the show
gee i must not know anything he said you
know i want you to be better and i go
i can't because if i'm not funny how can
i make myself
funny an unfunny guy can't be funny who
will be the news guy now on saturday
night live
i think maybe it's colin that's what it
says in the newspaper yeah and it says
you agreed to be replaced
well that sure is helen question what do
you get when you cross joey butterfucko
with a college education
answer i feel like i
sabotaged it because i felt so guilty
even i had nothing to do with norm
leaving
right but it was still wow i'm taking
i'm taking norm's thing
after they fire him it made me weird in
that spot the whole time i was there was
just like
it was like a curse hey norm did you
gain weight
i should have just left after a few
shows i should have said i can't do this
whatever the energy was that i was
bringing
i couldn't enjoy it at a bodega in
queens this week armed robbers stole
over 100 lottery tickets
the thieves made off with 6.5 million
dollars or nothing
lauren goes jimmy i think colin's
leaving and i think that we should you
know
i think the youth would be back into the
news and you and i go well that's not
what i would do i don't want to do
weekend update no thank you
he goes well just we're having auditions
and everyone's auditioning i go
but not me because i don't want to do it
i don't want to audition for something i
don't want then they're going to hire
this guy jeffrey ross
right funny comedian and they're gonna
hire him and then lauren goes
i really think it'd be better for the
show if it's someone that they know is
doing the news
not a new cast member because colin's
coming off so i go well
i'll do it but i want to do it with a
co-host i can't do it by myself right
and so we looked at the auditions that
we saw tina fey and we said oh cool a
michigan man was arrested for indecent
exposure
after his neighbors witnessed him having
sex with a pumpkin
what's most disturbing is that it was
anal sex
after jimmy fallon left amy starts
working with you
i felt like oh i guess i should want to
do it by myself i shouldn't
i should try to think like a guy and be
like me talking more
and i test alone and i i didn't it
didn't feel right and so i remember
calling him like
the week of the first show of that
season i remember going to amy and it
felt like i was asking her to marry me i
was like will you do me the great honor
a kitten that ran out of its carrier
case and a new york city subway platform
has been found after 25 days in the
underground tunnels
the kitten reportedly survived by
hooking up with a hip-hop dance crew
they had sarah palin and she said oh i
wrote a rap song but i can't perform it
and you came out and performed the rap
song in front of her and i was like
holy [ __ ] this is a weird moment i was
surreal on the thousand levels for me
that moment
my name is sarah palin you all know me
vice president
of the gop you know when people come on
the show
you have to be a good host it doesn't
work if you're mean to them
right it just doesn't work because you
you invited them into [ __ ] on them i
mean that's true
so they're coming they have a sense of
humor about themselves they're coming to
they know what they're in for what
they're signing up for
seth and i were just trying to think of
a bit that would be fun and i was
so pregnant i gave birth like five days
later
[Music]
[Applause]
how many jokes do you write for weekend
update there's like a hundred a day
and then on friday we hold a cow yeah
how many people
contribute to get a hundred three people
three people write 30 to 35 jokes each a
day
a baker in new zealand who got into an
argument with members of a wedding party
made a chocolate cake for the bride and
groom in the shape of a pile of feces
which begs the question who figured out
it was cake
were you instrumental in starting the
stefan character for bill hader i only
played one small part in the history of
that character so john mulaney and
bill hader came up with that character
the first time they did it was as a
sketch
with ben affleck and then they tried a
few more times as a sketch but the host
would always be like less inclined to do
it because they were just the straight
man
right but you're sitting next to
somebody who's killing right and you're
not getting
any laughs right and so the one thing
that i'll take credit for is i suggested
to them like hey do it on update because
i won't care
i'm happy to set them up that was some
vacation we took this summer
how's your back so stefan
[Applause]
saturday night live it's a huge part of
your life it's like the comedy military
when i
meet somebody from another season you
talk about it like
where were you stationed i stayed there
for nine seasons i liked the job i
wasn't using it as a stepping stone
for 12 and a half years i slept at 30
rock on tuesday night who is lauren's
favorite
let's think this through do all three of
you have the ability to text lorne
michaels
yeah you do yeah who would get the text
back first do you think
he represents so much to so many
different people the guy gave me the job
right yeah i mean that's what made you
what's wrong with the guy who gave me
that job
nothing